all right we have got some dangerous
near record Heat in store all the way
for the rest of the week and Ted
florinda was here to tell us just how
hot it's gonna get yeah Denise soon we
had some changes today 100 degrees our
official high for the day today and
guess what anytime we reach 100 degrees
or more good friends at HVAC will donate
$100 to two charities for pets and vets
that's our 100 degree guarantee thank
you so much HVAC for that 100 our high
for the day today
92% Teddy Hills right now 98 for Aliante
101 still for those of you in North Las
Vegas still hot on the east side sunrise
mountain coming 102 101 Whitney ranch 97
for mountains edge that's the southwest
part of value there Rhodes Ranch
included our friends also in Southern
Highlands 98 for anthem Centennial Hills
you're at 92 up there in Providence 98
for prop double nines for Boulder City
hot in Death Valley to 106 degrees that
same story further you down river in
Laughlin at this hour there's our desert
Doppler radar doing the sweeps picking
up clouds but no showers forgot a few
actually storms just like we said just
came off the leeward side of the
mountains the Sierras now moving into
our state some thunderstorm activity
there but we remain on the dry side
high pressure in charge this will build
in even more these next few days and
that allow the temperatures to really
ramp up like we said near record heat
for these next three days here 107 on
Wednesday same goes for Thursday Friday
down in digit but still way above
average for this time of year we should
be in the low to mid 90s for this time
of year 101 they'll Saturday with some
changes that next disturbance pushes its
way in and that's gonna bring us some
win signifying that change Friday and
Saturday gusty winds expected some
breezy winds also by Sunday and into
next week where we see more changes
we'll see in the 70 forecast in just a
bit
75 overnight clear and mild your winds
stay light tonight that's great tomorrow
pick up just a little bit we could see
them up to 10 to 15 in some locales
tomorrow we'll talk about near record
heat like we said 107 are forecasted
high the record 108 degrees set way back
in 1974 so we'll come close to that
maybe even tie it tomorrow our seven-day
forecast shows like we said that record
heat all the way through Friday hot with
clear to sunny to mostly sunny sky
and then we get to the weekend we start
to see those changes by Friday in the
form of wind there are those
temperatures will be knocked back down
the century mark and even cooler but
still warm next week at 92 degrees with
more clouds and more wind that is your
most accurate forecast
just nobody thank you